Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. It is about time, I proceeded, that some public-spirited person came along and told you where you got off. The trouble with you, Spode, is that just because you have succeeded in inducing a handful of halfwits to disfigure the London scene by going about in black shorts, you think you're someone. You hear them shouting hail spode and you imagine it is the voice of the people this is where you make your bloomer what the voice of the people is saying is look at that frightful ass spode swanking about in footer bags did you ever in your path see such a perfect per. But Dominic was a Bertie Worcester philosopher
感谢您收听《历史余温》。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我接着说，早该有个热心肠的人站出来告诉你该适可而止了。斯波德，你的问题在于，仅仅因为你成功诱骗了一小撮傻瓜，让他们穿着黑短裤在伦敦街头招摇过市，你就以为自己是个大人物了。你听着他们高喊“斯波德万岁”，就以为那是人民的声音，这就是你犯蠢的地方。人民的声音其实是在说：“快看那个穿着短裤招摇过市的蠢货斯波德，你这辈子见过这么完美的傻瓜吗？”但多米尼克是个伯蒂·伍斯特式的哲学家。
and political analyst in P.G. Woodhouse's The Code of the Worcesters, which he wrote in 1938. And Sir Roderick Spode, who's the kind of bogeyman in the Bertie Worcester stories, is a not-so-subtle portrait of Sir Oswald Moseley, who is the leader of the black shirts. So hence the black shorts that Spode wears. And the end of the first episode that we did, we were looking at the roots and the kind of the first emergings of British fascism. And you left it on this cliffhanger saying that British fascism needed a plausible leader.
以及 P.G. 伍德豪斯 1938 年所著《伍斯特准则》中的政治分析家。罗德里克·斯波德爵士，也就是伯蒂·伍斯特故事里的那个“妖怪”，其实是黑衫军领袖奥斯瓦尔德·莫斯利爵士的一个并不隐晦的写照。所以这就是斯波德穿黑短裤的原因。在我们制作的第一集结尾，我们探讨了英国法西斯主义的根源和最初的萌芽。你当时留下了一个悬念，说英国法西斯主义需要一个像样的领袖。
And it finds its plausible leader, or is he plausible? I mean, we can discuss that in the form of Sir Oswald Mosley, who is, as you said at the end of the previous episode, a fascinating character. I mean, very sinister character. You can see, just to repeat what we said in the last episode, you can see him being interviewed on ITV in 1970s. It's very, very odd. He's a remarkable character. And as you say, a much more complicated and fascinating individual than I think many people realize.
它找到了这位像样的领袖，或者说他真的像样吗？我的意思是，我们可以以奥斯瓦尔德·莫斯利爵士的形式来讨论这个问题，正如你在上一集结尾所说，他是一个迷人的人物。我的意思是，一个非常阴险的人物。就像我们在上一集所说的那样，你可以看到他在 1970 年代接受 ITV 采访的视频。非常、非常奇怪。他是一个非凡的人物。正如你所说，他是一个比我认为许多人意识到的要复杂和迷人得多的人。
So you hear the name fascist and you think, just a sinister pantomime villain. Mosley is not a pantomime villain at all. The one thing I will say, however, is that that brilliant reading made me realize for the first time the true nature of the rest of this history dynamic. You are Bertie. And you're Jeeves. Has that not occurred to you before, Tom? Alternatively, of course, I could be Bertie and you could be Gussie Fink-Nottle.
所以当你听到“法西斯”这个名字时，你会觉得他只是一个阴险的哑剧反派。莫斯利根本不是什么哑剧反派。不过，有一点我要说，那段精彩的朗读让我第一次意识到《历史余温》这种动态的本质。你是伯蒂，而我是吉夫斯。汤姆，你之前没意识到吗？或者，当然，我也可以是伯蒂，而你是加西·芬克-诺特。
I think I'm more Gussie Fink-Nottle. With my mutes. You'd just be mutes. Yeah, but you're a few steps for crickets, aren't you? And Gussie doesn't like crickets. No, there's the vicar, isn't there? The curate, who's awfully good at cricket. Is he Stilton Cheesewright?
我觉得我更像加西·芬克-诺特。带着我的蝾螈。你只会带着蝾螈。是的，但你对板球还是有几分了解的，不是吗？而加西不喜欢板球。不，还有那个牧师，对吧？那个非常擅长板球的副牧师。他是斯蒂尔顿·奇斯赖特吗？
No, Stinker Pinker. Stinker Pinker, of course. Stinker Pinker, very good. This will mean nothing to people who've never read P.G. Woodhouse. It would amaze people to know that we like
不，是斯廷克·平克。当然是斯廷克·平克，非常好。这对那些从未读过 P.G. 伍德豪斯的人来说毫无意义。如果人们知道我们喜欢
P.G. Woodhouse. They would never have anticipated that. So, Oswald Mosley, yes. So, at the end of the last episode, we talked about how British fascism got to the end of the 1920s.
P.G. 伍德豪斯，他们一定会感到惊讶。他们绝对预料不到。所以，奥斯瓦尔德·莫斯利，是的。在上一集结尾，我们谈到了英国法西斯主义是如何走到 1920 年代末的。
All the ingredients in some ways are there. I mean, Britain, of course, hasn't lost the First World War, which is a huge... It's a plus. Yeah, it's a plus for Britain, a minus if you're a fascist. But the anti-Semitism, the anxiety about Bolshevism, the belief that Britain has become corrupted, the distrust of democracy, parliamentary democracy. All of those ingredients are floating around, not just politically, but they're in the national imagination and John Buckner and Agatha Christie and Bulldog Drummond and all
在某些方面，所有的要素都齐备了。我的意思是，英国当然没有输掉第一次世界大战，这是一个巨大的……这是一个加分项。是的，对英国来说是加分项，但如果你是法西斯分子，那就是减分项。但是反犹太主义、对布尔什维主义的焦虑、认为英国已经腐败的信念、对民主和议会民主的不信任。所有这些要素都在四处飘荡，不仅是在政治上，而且存在于国民的想象中，约翰·巴肯、阿加莎·克里斯蒂、《斗牛犬德拉蒙德》以及所有
these things. But they lack the front man, and the front man they're going to find is Oswald Mosley. Now, Mosley, as I said, is a really remarkable figure. He was born in 1896, and he comes from a kind of family of Staffordshire landowners. So that's in the West Midlands for those people who are not from Britain. That's where the Hollands come from. It's where the Sandbrookes, it's not far from where I grew up. His mother has a family home in Shropshire, my home county, but Mosley spends most of his time at his grandfather's house, which is Rolston Hall in Staffordshire. His grandfather,
这些东西里。但他们缺少一个领军人物，而他们即将找到的领军人物就是奥斯瓦尔德·莫斯利。现在，莫斯利，正如我所说，是一个非常了不起的人物。他出生于 1896 年，来自斯塔福德郡的一个地主家庭。对于那些不是英国人的人来说，那是在西米德兰兹。那是霍兰家族的故乡。那是桑德布鲁克家族的故乡，离我长大的地方不远。他的母亲在我的家乡什罗普郡有一个家庭住宅，但莫斯利大部分时间都待在他祖父的家里，也就是斯塔福德郡的罗尔斯顿庄园。他的祖父，
Tom, was supposed to look just like John Bull and was in fact called John Bull. His grandfather was nicknamed John Bull. And young Sir Oswald, or Tom, as his friends and family called him, in that sort of way that the British aristocracy did in the early 20th century. Yeah, so like Boris Johnson was called Alex by his family. But his name was Alex. I mean, he was christened Alex. So young Tom Moseley, he grows up there. His mother and father had parted company when he was five. So he has his grandfather, John Bull, but he doesn't have a father figure,
汤姆，据说长得就像“约翰牛”，事实上也被称为“约翰牛”。他的祖父绰号就叫“约翰牛”。年轻的奥斯瓦尔德爵士，或者像他的朋友和家人那样称呼他为“汤姆”，这是 20 世纪初英国贵族的一种习惯。是的，就像鲍里斯·约翰逊被家人称为“亚历克斯”一样。但他的名字是亚历克斯。我的意思是，他受洗时就叫亚历克斯。所以年轻的汤姆·莫斯利就在那里长大。他的父母在他五岁时就分开了。所以他有他的祖父“约翰牛”，但他没有父亲的形象，
and he's a very spoiled little boy. His mother, we talked in the last episode about Rota Linton Orman, the founder of the British fascists. She was called the man-woman. Well, Oswald Moses' mother called him her man-child. And to some extent, I think there's an argument by Robert Skidelsky, his biographer, that he remained a man-child all his life, this sort of spoiled brat. The Peter Pan of mid-war British politics. But I think there is an element to that, Tom.
他是一个非常被宠坏的小男孩。关于他的母亲，我们在上一集谈到了英国法西斯主义者创始人罗塔·林顿·奥曼。她被称为“男人婆”。嗯，奥斯瓦尔德·莫斯利的母亲称他为她的“男人孩”。在某种程度上，我认为他的传记作者罗伯特·斯基德尔斯基有一个论点，即他一生都保持着“男人孩”的状态，就像一个被宠坏的顽童。战间期英国政治的彼得·潘。但我认为这其中确实有某种成分，汤姆。
He's impatient. He wants everything now. He won't take no for an answer. And as we will see, those things lead him into progressively more and more trouble. To become Captain Hook. To become Captain Hook. Very good. So he goes to Winchester College, Rishi Sunak's old school. He's a very tall, sporty kind of person. He's
他很没耐心。他想要现在就得到一切。他不接受“不”作为答案。正如我们将要看到的，这些特质使他陷入了越来越多的麻烦。变成了虎克船长。变成了虎克船长。非常好。所以他去了温彻斯特公学，那是里希·苏纳克的老学校。他是一个非常高大、热爱运动的人。他
quite a loner and he's quite haughty. People say of him at school that he sort of keeps himself to himself and he thinks himself better than the other boys. He's a brilliant fencer. So he wins the public schools fencing championship in both foil and saber. And had he not been injured in the first world war, his biographers say it's plausible he would have won the World Fencing Championship. He goes to Sandhurst Military Training School for Officers in the early 1914 when he's 17 years old. He has a fight at Sandhurst with some other boys, young men, and he fractures his right
相当孤僻，而且相当傲慢。学校里的人说他有点独来独往，认为自己比其他男孩强。他是一名出色的击剑手。所以他赢得了公立学校击剑锦标赛的重剑和佩剑冠军。如果他没有在第一次世界大战中受伤，他的传记作者说，他很有可能赢得世界击剑锦标赛。1914 年初，他 17 岁时进入桑德赫斯特军事学院接受军官培训。他在桑德赫斯特与一些其他男孩、年轻人打架，弄断了他的右
ankle. This is the first in a series of breaks that will end up leaving him with this limp. He then, when the war breaks out, he joins the Royal Flying Corps. He gets a pilot's license and he's showing off at an air show type thing, a demonstration in front of his mother in 1915 when he crashes his plane and breaks the same ankle. He breaks it again. But then because of the demands for men in the First World War, he's sent to the trenches before his leg has properly healed. And he spends months in the
脚踝。这是一系列骨折中的第一次，最终导致他留下了跛脚。然后，当战争爆发时，他加入了皇家飞行队。他获得了飞行员执照，并在 1915 年在他母亲面前进行了一次飞行表演，当时他坠机并弄断了同一只脚踝。他又把它弄断了。但由于第一次世界大战对兵力的需求，他在腿还没完全愈合的情况下就被送到了战壕。他在
trenches under fire, but eventually he is evacuated, sent home for operations on this leg, which hasn't healed properly. They save his leg, but he is left with a permanent limp. That is, by the way, a great asset to him. It means he has a genuine kind of war wound, a very visible war wound, but that's not otherwise incapacitated him. And that experience of war generally is immensely important for Moseley. So Robert Skidelsky, his biographer, I think we'll talk a little bit about Robert Skidelsky's biography in this, because Lord Skidelsky, as he now is, is most famous as the biography of John Maynard Keynes. And his biography of Moseley, the first to take Moseley seriously,
战壕里在炮火下待了几个月，但最终他被撤离，送回家对这条没能完全愈合的腿进行手术。他们保住了他的腿，但他留下了永久性的跛脚。顺便说一句，这对他是巨大的资产。这意味着他有一种真实的战争创伤，一种非常明显的战争创伤，但并没有让他丧失行动能力。而那种战争经历对莫斯利来说通常是非常重要的。所以罗伯特·斯基德尔斯基，他的传记作者，我想我们会在这方面谈谈罗伯特·斯基德尔斯基的传记，因为斯基德尔斯基勋爵（他现在是这个头衔）最出名的是作为约翰·梅纳德·凯恩斯的传记作者。而他写的莫斯利传记，是第一部认真对待莫斯利的传记，
torpedoed Skidelsky's academic career. He was denied tenure at Johns Hopkins University in the United States because his biography was seen as soft on Moseley. And he never got a job at Oxbridge for the same reason, so he ended up professor at Warwick. And he never got a job at Oxbridge for the same reason. So he ended up professor at Warwick. And he's one of Britain's most eminent public intellectuals. But because he took Mosley seriously and he said,
摧毁了斯基德尔斯基的学术生涯。他在美国约翰霍普金斯大学被拒绝授予终身教职，因为他的传记被认为对莫斯利过于宽容。他也因为同样的原因没能在牛剑获得职位，所以他最终成为了华威大学的教授。他也因为同样的原因没能在牛剑获得职位。所以他最终成为了华威大学的教授。他是英国最杰出的公共知识分子之一。但因为他认真对待莫斯利，并且他说，
he's not just a villain. You know, there's lots of interesting things. And he was really strong on Mosley's relationship with the economist John Maynard Keynes and the links between Mosleyism and Keynesianism. Is that what made him interested in? Yes, I think it is.
他不仅仅是一个反派。你知道，有很多有趣的事情。而且他在莫斯利与经济学家约翰·梅纳德·凯恩斯的关系，以及莫斯利主义与凯恩斯主义之间的联系方面非常有力。这就是让他感兴趣的原因吗？是的，我想是的。
I think it is, exactly. So Mosley is, of all fascist leaders, I think by far the most interesting. And he is a sinister man, but he's clever, genuine, and thoughtful in a way that is not true necessarily, certainly not true of Hitler, and not true of Mussolini.
我想是的，确实如此。所以莫斯利是所有法西斯领袖中，我认为迄今为止最有趣的一个。他是一个阴险的人，但他聪明、真诚且有思想，这在希特勒身上不一定适用，在墨索里尼身上也绝对不适用。
So Mosley comes back from the war, and he's very typical of lots of young men of his generation, of his class. Harold McMillan is a really good example, the British prime minister in the 50s and 60s. Anthony Eden, actually, as well. Clement Attlee? Well, Clement Attlee, to some degree, I guess. Well, Clement Attlee injured in Mesopotamia, Major Attlee.
所以莫斯利从战争中回来，他是他那一代、他那个阶层许多年轻人的典型代表。哈罗德·麦克米伦就是一个很好的例子，50 和 60 年代的英国首相。安东尼·艾登，其实也是。克莱门特·艾德礼？嗯，克莱门特·艾德礼，在某种程度上，我想是的。嗯，克莱门特·艾德礼在美索不达米亚受伤，艾德礼少校。
There is this whole generation of young men who come out of the war. They want a new start. They are really full of dissatisfaction when they get back to Britain. Not the same kind of dissatisfaction as the John Buchan heroes we talked about in the last episode. But resentment of old men, isn't it? The old men. The old men who sent us to war and are still running the country. Lloyd George, the corrupt old man, all of these people. So Mosley comes back and he's fired up with that. And he's also fired up with the sense of brotherhood that so many people have from the trenches. Same kind of brotherhood that you see reflected actually in the Lord of the Rings or something,
整整一代年轻人从战争中走出来。他们想要一个新的开始。当他们回到英国时，他们真的充满了不满。不是我们上一集谈到的约翰·巴肯英雄们那种不满。而是对老人的怨恨，不是吗？那些老人。那些把我们送上战场，现在还在管理国家的老人。劳合·乔治，那个腐败的老人，所有这些人。所以莫斯利回来了，他被那种情绪点燃了。他也因为在战壕中许多人所拥有的那种兄弟情谊而感到振奋。那种你在《指环王》之类的作品中看到的兄弟情谊，
J.R.R. Tolkien, Frodo and Sam. Mosley comes back. He's obviously still got all his kind of aristocratic connections. He becomes a very popular guest at the sort of dinner parties and salons in London. Lady Astor, Lady Colfax, Lady Cunard. And he's a philanderer. So he, as Skidelsky says, mostly slept with the hostesses and was taken up by the politicians.
J.R.R. 托尔金，弗罗多和山姆。莫斯利回来了。他显然仍然拥有他所有的那种贵族关系。他成为了伦敦各种晚宴和沙龙中非常受欢迎的客人。阿斯特夫人、科尔法克斯夫人、库纳德夫人。他是个花花公子。所以，正如斯基德尔斯基所说，莫斯利睡了女主人，并被政客们接纳。
This was the period of his apprenticeship, his substitute for a university. As his confidence grew, the seduced turned into the seducer. The conqueror of the bedroom became the coquette of the platform. So he's a great hit at these parties, and he's taken up by the conservatives, and he becomes the conservative candidate for Harrow in 1918. He says right at the time, he says, my policy is socialistic imperialism. So it's a very kind of red Toryism. He actually has red posters, red rosettes. And he wants lots of state control of things, a real break with kind of laissez-faire conservatism.
这是他的学徒期，他大学的替代品。随着他的自信心增强，被诱惑者变成了诱惑者。卧室的征服者变成了讲台上的调情者。所以他在这些聚会上非常受欢迎，并被保守党接纳，他在 1918 年成为哈罗区的保守党候选人。他当时就说，他说，我的政策是“社会主义帝国主义”。所以这是一种非常红色的托利主义。他实际上有红色的海报，红色的花结。他想要国家对事物进行大量的控制，这与那种自由放任的保守主义是真正的决裂。
The conservatives are really in flux at this period. So nobody really notices. It's fine. He can get away with it. He goes into the commons. He's the baby of the house, said the youngest member. He's only 22. And he straightaway gets a reputation as a very sort of slashing speaker.
保守党在这一时期确实处于动荡之中。所以没人真正注意到。没关系。他可以蒙混过关。他进入了下议院。他是议会中最年轻的成员。他才 22 岁。他立刻就以一个非常犀利的演讲者而闻名。
His maiden speech is an attack on Winston Churchill, who's got two jobs. And he says, you can't reasonably have two jobs, minister of war and minister of air. He's keen on feminism. So he's kind of forward thinking and modern. He sets himself up as the spokesman in Britain, the political spokesman for the younger generation. And he's very articulate. This is 1919. Beware lest old age steal back and rob you of your reward. Lest old dead men with their old dead So that's him sort of speaking to youth and that stuff about cleansed in the blood. Of course, that sounds very sinister to Ares now. We might say, ah, there's a sign of the fascism.
他的处女演讲是对温斯顿·丘吉尔的攻击，当时丘吉尔身兼两职。他说，你不能合理地拥有两份工作，战争大臣和航空大臣。他热衷于女权主义。所以他有点前瞻性和现代感。他把自己定位为英国年轻一代的政治代言人。他非常善于表达。这是 1919 年。当心老年人偷走并夺走你的回报。当心那些带着陈旧死气沉沉的老人……所以这就是他在向年轻人讲话，还有关于“在鲜血中洗礼”之类的话。当然，这对现在的我们来说听起来非常阴险。我们可能会说，啊，那是法西斯主义的迹象。
But I mean, people are talking like that all the time in 1918, 1919, 1920. He marries really well. So about the time that he's making that speech, he meets Lord Curzon's daughter, Cynthia, or Simi, as she's known. Lord Curzon, the former Viceroy of India, very big man in conservative politics. Great enthusiast for the Taj Mahal. Great enthusiast for the Taj Mahal. Great enthusiast for the Taj Mahal. Quite right, Tom.
但我的意思是，人们在 1918 年、1919 年、1920 年一直都在那样说话。他娶得非常好。所以在他发表那次演讲的时候，他遇到了寇松勋爵的女儿辛西娅，或者像她所知的那样，西米。寇松勋爵，前印度总督，保守党政治中的大人物。泰姬陵的狂热爱好者。泰姬陵的狂热爱好者。泰姬陵的狂热爱好者。说得对，汤姆。
A most superior person, Lord Curzon, the most superior person on the planet in his own estimation anyway. Can't open a window. So if he wants the window open, throws logs out through the pane of glass. Yeah. So to marry Lord Curzon's daughter is a very impressive thing. They marry. It's a sign of Moses' importance at that point, his connections, that the king is there,
一个极其优越的人，寇松勋爵，至少在他自己的估计中是地球上最优越的人。连窗户都打不开。所以如果他想开窗，就把木头扔出玻璃窗。是的。所以娶寇松勋爵的女儿是一件非常令人印象深刻的事情。他们结婚了。这是莫斯利当时重要性及其人脉的标志，国王出席了，
George V, the queen is there, the king and queen of Belgium are there. So presumably these are Curzon's guests rather than Mosley's. But even so, it's a remarkable thing. Mosley is never faithful to his wife. He's still messing around with married women at all these political salons and there's a wonderful story that in 1933 he told another very rakish mp robert boothby he says to boothby i've i've come clean to simi i've told her about all my other women and boothby said all of them tom and uh mostly said well all of them except her stepmother and her sister.
乔治五世，王后出席了，比利时国王和王后也出席了。所以大概这些是寇松的客人，而不是莫斯利的。但即便如此，这也是一件了不起的事情。莫斯利从未对他的妻子忠诚。他仍然在所有这些政治沙龙里和已婚妇女鬼混，有一个精彩的故事，1933 年他告诉另一个非常放荡的议员罗伯特·布斯比，他对布斯比说，我向西米坦白了，我告诉了她关于我所有其他女人的事，布斯比说，所有的吗，汤姆？呃，莫斯利说，嗯，除了她的继母和她的姐妹。
I see. Hello. That's Terry Thomas. And there is a bit of the Terry Thomas about him. Me? Sir Oswald Mosley? In a dormitory for French maids? What were they thinking? Right. If you don't know who Terry Thomas is,
我明白了。你好。那是特里·托马斯。他身上确实有一点特里·托马斯的影子。我？奥斯瓦尔德·莫斯利爵士？在法国女仆的宿舍里？他们在想什么？对。如果你不知道特里·托马斯是谁，
so that would be all of our overseas listeners, just Google him. Thomas' impersonation actually is quite good, but I think we don't want to... No, I was doing... That was the guy from the Fast Show. So it's an impression of an impression. Right. It was an impression of an impression, yes. At the end of 1920, Mosley leaves the Conservatives. He walks out to the Conservative Party. And actually, the breach is because he attacks them about the use of the Black and Tans, the auxiliaries in Ireland. That is ironic.
那将是我们所有的海外听众，去谷歌一下他。托马斯的模仿其实相当不错，但我认为我们不想……不，我是在做……那是《快秀》里的那个人。所以这是对模仿的模仿。对，这是对模仿的模仿，是的。1920 年底，莫斯利离开了保守党。他退出了保守党。事实上，决裂的原因是他攻击他们关于在爱尔兰使用“黑与棕”辅助部队的问题。这很讽刺。
To fight, yeah. The use of paramilitaries effectively. So he's opposed to the use of paramilitary forces. Correct. And the funny thing is, you see, Mosley at this point is a very, he is modern. He is progressive. He is forward thinking. Well, fascism is modern as well, isn't it? Well, this is the thing. British fascism, I think, is unusually modern by the standards of European fascisms in the 1920s and 30s. So actually, you don't get as much of the medievalism, the faux archaic stuff. So that's why there's no King Arthur,
去战斗，是的。实际上是使用准军事部队。所以他反对使用准军事部队。正确。有趣的是，你看，莫斯利在这一点上是非常现代的。他是进步的，他是前瞻性的。嗯，法西斯主义也是现代的，不是吗？嗯，这就是问题所在。英国法西斯主义，我认为，按照 1920 年代和 30 年代欧洲法西斯主义的标准，是非常现代的。所以实际上，你没有那么多中世纪主义，那种伪古风的东西。所以这就是为什么没有亚瑟王，
which we talked about in the previous episode. Right. So first, he's an independent, spends some time as an independent, and then he decides he's going to join the Labour Party. This is not that unusual. There is quite a lot. I mean, Martin Pugh, who wrote Hurrah for the Black Shirts, he wrote a history of the Labour Party. And one of his really big and interesting points was about the crossover, not between Labour and the Liberals, but between the Labour and the Tories. There were quite a lot of people who moved from the Tories into Labour in the 1920s, including lots of working-class voters. Stanley Baldwin's son, Clement Attlee, came from a Tory family,
我们在上一集谈到过。对。所以首先，他是一个独立人士，花了一些时间作为独立人士，然后他决定加入工党。这并不罕见。有很多。我的意思是，写了《为黑衫军欢呼》的马丁·普，他写了一部工党史。他真正重要且有趣的一点是关于交叉，不是在工党和自由党之间，而是在工党和托利党之间。在 1920 年代，有很多人从托利党转入工党，包括许多工人阶级选民。斯坦利·鲍德温的儿子，克莱门特·艾德礼，来自一个托利党家庭，
not a Liberal family, a Tory family. So there were a lot of people who thought the Liberals are kind of high-minded, vegetarian, weedy... Prune juice drinkers. Prune juice drinking bookish people. And actually, I'm a patriotic working man, or champion of the working man, the working man's pint, the empire, all of that kind of thing. But I believe that the miners should have better wages. And mostly joins the Labour Party, and the Labour
不是自由党家庭，是一个托利党家庭。所以有很多人认为自由党是那种高尚的、素食的、虚弱的……喝西梅汁的人。喝西梅汁、书呆子气的人。而实际上，我是一个爱国的工人，或者工人的拥护者，工人的品脱，帝国，所有这些东西。但我相信矿工应该有更好的工资。莫斯利加入了工党，工党
Party are delighted to have him. They are thrilled. There's a wonderful description in Martin Pugh's book of him going to a big Labour Party meeting, 2,000 people there. Moseley goes onto the platform. The crowd of Labour Party supporters sing for he's a jolly good fellow. A lady in furs, an elegant lady in furs gets up to give a speech of introduction and a whisper goes around, Lady Cynthia, Lady Cynthia Moseley, Lord Curzon's daughter. They love it. They can't get enough of this.
很高兴拥有他。他们非常激动。马丁·普的书里有一段精彩的描述，他去参加一个大型工党会议，那里有 2000 人。莫斯利走上讲台。工党支持者的人群唱着“他是一个快乐的好小伙”。一位穿着皮草的女士，一位优雅的穿着皮草的女士站起来发表介绍演讲，人群中传出低语：“辛西娅夫人，辛西娅·莫斯利夫人，寇松勋爵的女儿。”他们喜欢它。他们对这些东西乐此不疲。
Mosley is a big star. So when he says he's going to join Labour, 70 Labour constituency parties ask him to be their candidate. He's a fighter. He chooses Birmingham, the home of popular Toryism, because he wants to stand against Neville Chamberlain. And he loses by only 77 votes in the Chamberlain stronghold in Birmingham, the absolute heartland of kind of working class, true blue conservatism. That makes his name. People say, my God, he took on the toughest fight and he almost won it. So he then gets a seat in Smethwick in the West Midlands. And he is an absolute star. He's very prominent in the Labour Party.
莫斯利是一个大明星。所以当他说他要加入工党时，70 个工党选区要求他成为他们的候选人。他是一个斗士。他选择了伯明翰，大众托利党的大本营，因为他想与内维尔·张伯伦竞争。他在伯明翰的张伯伦据点，那个工人阶级、真正的蓝色保守主义的绝对中心，仅以 77 票之差落败。这让他名声大噪。人们说，天哪，他接受了最艰难的战斗，而且差点就赢了。所以他随后在西米德兰兹的斯梅斯威克获得了一个席位。他是一个绝对的明星。他在工党中非常突出。
Is that Enoch Powell's seat? Enoch Powell's seat is in Wolverhampton. Smethwick is very, very close, just a few miles away in the black country. But Smethwick is famous because there was a by-election there in the 1960s with a racist campaign. So mostly, there he is, he's the MP from Smethwick. He throws himself into Labour Party politics. He tours the slums.
那是伊诺克·鲍威尔的席位吗？伊诺克·鲍威尔的席位在伍尔弗汉普顿。斯梅斯威克非常、非常近，就在黑乡几英里外。但斯梅斯威克很有名，因为 1960 年代那里进行了一场带有种族主义竞选活动的补选。所以莫斯利，他就在那里，他是斯梅斯威克的议员。他全身心投入到工党政治中。他巡视贫民窟。
He goes and visits coal miners. He goes to mining villages all over Britain. He gives donations to miners who've been on strike. He's very close to the miners' leader, Arthur Cook. He goes to India. He goes to the United States. He goes fishing with Franklin D. Roosevelt in the United States to pick up ideas. He is elected three times to the National Executive of the Labour Party, the NEC, 1927, 28, and 1930. And he will end up falling out with the Labour Party, but not because he's too right-wing, quite the reverse in some ways. In 1925, Mosley had written a book or co-authored a book by a friend of his called John Strakey, a member of the Labour Party, called Revolution by Reason. It was an economic book
他去拜访煤矿工人。他去英国各地的矿村。他向罢工的矿工捐款。他与矿工领袖亚瑟·库克关系非常密切。他去印度。他去美国。他在美国和富兰克林·D·罗斯福一起钓鱼，以获取想法。他三次当选为工党全国执行委员会（NEC）成员，1927 年、28 年和 1930 年。他最终会与工党闹翻，但不是因为他太右翼，在某些方面恰恰相反。1925 年，莫斯利写了一本书，或者与他的朋友、工党成员约翰·斯特雷奇合著了一本书，名为《理性的革命》。这是一本经济学书籍，
that, as Robert Skidelsky says in his biography of Moseley, anticipates what John Maynard Keynes is going to say about the right economic formula to ensure a successful, prosperous society. So invest money in public works. Yeah, and invest money in public works, fight unemployment, create demand. There's not enough demand. People don't have enough money to join in the new emerging consumer society. That's why there's so much unemployment. If you create demand, if you put money in people's pockets, then they will go out and
正如罗伯特·斯基德尔斯基在他的莫斯利传记中所说，预见了约翰·梅纳德·凯恩斯关于确保一个成功、繁荣社会的正确经济公式的说法。所以投资公共工程。是的，投资公共工程，对抗失业，创造需求。需求不足。人们没有足够的钱加入新的新兴消费社会。这就是为什么失业率这么高。如果你创造需求，如果你把钱放进人们的口袋里，那么他们就会出去
spend, and that will create this kind of virtuous circle. This is a very simplified version of Keynesianism. Skidelsky says of Mosley's ideas, it was a precise foreshadowing of the Keynesian philosophy of demand management. They minus the theory that justified it. Now, he comes up with this in Britain, because in Britain, unlike in the United States, unemployment is really high in the 20s. So by 1930, unemployment had gone up to 2.5 million, which is about 16% of the workforce, so much higher. It's one reason why the Depression is not so much a shock in
消费，这将创造这种良性循环。这是凯恩斯主义的一个非常简化的版本。斯基德尔斯基谈到莫斯利的思想时说，这是对需求管理凯恩斯主义哲学的精确预示。减去证明它的理论。现在，他在英国提出了这一点，因为在英国，与美国不同，20 年代的失业率非常高。所以到 1930 年，失业人数上升到 250 万，约占劳动力的 16%，所以高得多。这是大萧条在
Britain, because actually Britain's kind of been in this mess all along since the end of the First World War. Labour get in in the 1929 election, Ramsay MacDonald. But Ramsay MacDonald, the leader of the Labour Party, and the people around him are economically much more conservative than Moseley. They don't believe in borrowing and spending lots of money on public works. They believe that it's the job of a Labour Party to show that they're responsible by running the economy in the sort of rigorous, conservative way that a Tory government would have done. And in February 1930, Moseley writes this memorandum called the Moseley Memorandum, which most historians, lots of historians of early 20th century Britain would say is one of the absolute kind of landmark, most fascinating documents because it's a really detailed blueprint, far more detailed than anything produced by any other fascist leader, calling for basically a complete Keynesian
英国并没有那么令人震惊的原因之一，因为实际上自第一次世界大战结束以来，英国一直处于这种混乱之中。工党在 1929 年的选举中获胜，拉姆齐·麦克唐纳。但拉姆齐·麦克唐纳，工党领袖，以及他周围的人在经济上比莫斯利保守得多。他们不相信借钱和在公共工程上花大钱。他们认为工党的职责是通过以托利党政府会采取的那种严谨、保守的方式管理经济来证明他们是负责任的。1930 年 2 月，莫斯利写了这份名为《莫斯利备忘录》的文件，许多历史学家，许多 20 世纪初英国的历史学家会说这是绝对的里程碑，最迷人的文件之一，因为它是一个非常详细的蓝图，远比任何其他法西斯领袖制作的任何东西都要详细，基本上呼吁建立一个完整的凯恩斯
model for the British economy. So he wants a sort of inner cabinet of experts from industry and economics professors and businessmen and stuff. He wants an economic general staff run by Keynes that will plan the national economy and the national interest. He wants to borrow and spend 200 million pounds on public works to create jobs for people, all of this kind of stuff. And actually what it anticipates is the New Deal. So for our American listeners, Franklin D. Roosevelt's New Deal. But does it not also, it anticipates what will become
模式的英国经济。所以他想要一个由工业界、经济学教授和商人等组成的专家内阁。他想要一个由凯恩斯领导的经济总参谋部，来规划国民经济和国家利益。他想要借钱并花费 2 亿英镑在公共工程上，为人们创造就业机会，所有这些东西。实际上它预示的是“新政”。所以对于我们的美国听众来说，富兰克林·D·罗斯福的“新政”。但它难道没有预示着后来会成为
Nazi economics? The idea that you don't depend on economic policy for elected politicians because you can't trust them. You have a sense of what is good for the nation that is divorced from parliamentary politics. A little bit, yes. Funnily enough, Tom, the emphasis on experts is a very fascist thing. So the idea that you bring in disinterested people, not tainted, as you say, not tainted by parliamentary politics, not corrupted, they will come in and they will plan the national economy. That's something that lots of people in Mussolini's Italy would have said, oh, we've been doing this for years. This is also something that people involved with Roosevelt's New Deal would say, who are obviously not fascists, but are interested in what Mussolini
纳粹经济学的东西吗？那种你不依赖民选政客的经济政策，因为你不能信任他们的想法。你有一种对国家有益的感觉，这种感觉与议会政治脱节。有一点，是的。有趣的是，汤姆，对专家的强调是非常法西斯的东西。所以那种你引入公正的人，没有被污染，正如你所说，没有被议会政治污染，没有腐败，他们会进来并规划国民经济。这是墨索里尼意大利的许多人会说，“哦，我们已经这样做多年了。”这也是参与罗斯福“新政”的人会说的事情，他们显然不是法西斯分子，但对墨索里尼正在做的事情感兴趣。
is doing. They would say, yeah, this makes sense. Set up a big board of experts. Five-year plans are all the rage in Soviet Union, but you also have this on the right. Again, you have the sense that for parliamentary democracies, fashion is moving against them on both the left and the right, the flanks. I think that's right. This is the future. This is the future. Moseley takes it to the old men in the Labour cabinet and they say, no, we don't like it. He takes it to the whole meeting of the Labour parliamentary party and they back the leadership, not him. But interestingly, a couple of the people who do back him,
他们会说，是的，这有道理。建立一个大型专家委员会。五年计划在苏联很流行，但你在右翼也有这个。同样，你有一种感觉，对于议会民主制来说，时尚正在左翼和右翼两翼反对它们。我认为那是对的。这是未来。这是未来。莫斯利把它带给工党内阁的老人们，他们说，不，我们不喜欢它。他把它带到工党议会党的全体会议上，他们支持领导层，而不是他。但有趣的是，有几个人确实支持他，
two of his chief supporters, one of them is Stanley Baldwin's son, Oliver, Tom, who we've talked about before. Another one is now secular saint for the British left, and Aaron Bevan, founder of the National Health Service. He also backs Moseley and says his way is the way to go. But Moseley doesn't get his way. So he doesn't immediately walk out of the Labour Party. He's gearing up for a strop. He is. He goes to the Labour Party conference and his plan is defeated by 1.2 million votes to 1 million votes. These are big votes controlled by the trade unions often. But he still wins election to the National Executive Committee of the Labour Party at that late stage. However,
他的两个主要支持者，其中一个是斯坦利·鲍德温的儿子奥利弗，汤姆，我们之前谈到过。另一个现在是英国左翼的世俗圣人，阿奈林·贝文，国家医疗服务体系的创始人。他也支持莫斯利，并说他的方式是前进的方向。但莫斯利没有如愿。所以他没有立即走出工党。他正在准备一场风暴。他是。他去参加工党会议，他的计划以 120 万票对 100 万票被否决。这些通常是由工会控制的大票。但他仍然在那个后期阶段赢得了工党全国执行委员会的选举。然而，
because his memorandum hasn't been accepted, because he is a bit of a spoiled brat, because he is impatient, the man-child, sick of the old men, all that stuff, he flounces out of the Labour Party. And in February 1931, with backing from the car manufacturer, William Morris, so who ends up founding the famous, in Britain anyway, famous Nuffield Charitable Enterprises, all the Nuffield hospitals and the Nuffield studies and all that sort of thing. With backing from Morris, he sets up a new political party,
因为他的备忘录没有被接受，因为他有点被宠坏的顽童，因为他没耐心，那个“男人孩”，厌倦了老人们，所有这些东西，他愤然离开了工党。1931 年 2 月，在汽车制造商威廉·莫里斯的支持下，他最终创立了著名的（至少在英国是著名的）纳菲尔德慈善企业，所有的纳菲尔德医院和纳菲尔德研究等等。在莫里斯的支持下，他建立了一个新的政党，
not the British Union of Fascists, but it is called, excitingly, the New Party. So at that stage, Baldwin's son is one of his backers. Baldwin's son supports him. But Baldwin's son then later reverses and goes back into the Labour Party. And even at that point, when they had New Party meetings, they are harangued by hecklers. Now that, by the way, is absolutely standard in British politics in the early 20th century. This isn't something that came in with fascism. There'd always been rowdiness and punch-ups and heckling and shouting at political meetings. It was established for political parties to have stewards who would kind of get stuck
不是英国法西斯联盟，但它被称为，令人兴奋地，新党。所以在那个阶段，鲍德温的儿子是他的一位支持者。鲍德温的儿子支持他。但鲍德温的儿子后来反悔并回到了工党。即使在那个时候，当他们举行新党会议时，他们也会受到抗议者的质问。顺便说一句，这在 20 世纪初的英国政治中是绝对标准的。这不是随着法西斯主义而来的东西。政治会议上一直有吵闹、打架、质问和叫喊。政治党派有管事的人来处理抗议者是惯例，
into the hecklers. And even at this point, Mosley has a group of people who are called the Biff boys. These are the ones who are trained by the England rugby captain. Is that right? So the England rugby captain, Peter Howard is one of his supporters. There's also a boxer called Kid Lewis,
他们会陷入抗议者中。即使在这一点上，莫斯利也有一群被称为“Biff 男孩”的人。这些是由英格兰橄榄球队长训练的人。那是真的吗？所以英格兰橄榄球队长彼得·霍华德是他的支持者之一。还有一个叫基德·刘易斯的拳击手，
who is one of his supporters. And they're kind of, you know, having punch-ups with communists and people who are still in the Labour Party who are shouting at Mosley during these meetings. But his timing is terrible because in 1931, British politics is overcome by complete crisis, complete financial crisis. The Labour cabinet splits irrevocably and the king, George V, brokers a deal where a rump Labour government led by Ramsay MacDonald will get into bed with Stanley Baldwin's Conservatives and part of the Liberal Party, so a national government.
他是他的支持者之一。他们，你知道，在这些会议期间与共产主义者和仍然在工党中对莫斯利大喊大叫的人打架。但他的时机很糟糕，因为在 1931 年，英国政治被彻底的危机、彻底的金融危机所淹没。工党内阁不可挽回地分裂了，国王乔治五世促成了一项协议，由拉姆齐·麦克唐纳领导的工党残余政府将与斯坦利·鲍德温的保守党和自由党的一部分结盟，即国民政府。
And they go to the country in October 1931, and they win the biggest victory in the history of British politics. The rest of the Labour Party, who are against the national government, are reduced to 52 seats. The national government, dominated by Baldwin's Tories, win pretty much all the other seats. And the new party wins just 0.2% of the vote, and it's utterly overwhelmed. And so Mosley, who's flounced out of the Labour Party- Struts out, one might almost say. Right. Yes. I'm surprised you don't say he's goose-stepped out of the Labour Party. Struts out, one might almost say. Right. Yes. I'm surprised you don't say he's goose-stepped out of the... He's walked out of the Labour Party. He looks like a fool now. That said, he doesn't have to become a fascist. So lots of people... He's still having dinner with people like... Dinner parties with Churchill,
他们在 1931 年 10 月走向全国，赢得了英国政治史上最大的胜利。反对国民政府的工党其余部分被削减到 52 个席位。由鲍德温的托利党主导的国民政府赢得了几乎所有其他席位。而新党仅赢得了 0.2% 的选票，并被彻底淹没。所以莫斯利，他愤然离开了工党——大摇大摆地走出来，人们几乎可以这样说。对。是的。我很惊讶你没有说他是“鹅步”走出工党的。大摇大摆地走出来，人们几乎可以这样说。对。是的。我很惊讶你没有说他是……他走出了工党。他现在看起来像个傻瓜。话虽如此，他不必成为法西斯分子。所以很多人……他仍然和像……丘吉尔、
with Lloyd George, with lots of people who like an eccentric, they like a character. And both the Conservatives and the Labour Party would be very happy to welcome him back. But mostly has got it into his head that by forming this coalition, this national government, they have signed their own death warrant, that they will fail to deal with the economic crisis, they will be overwhelmed, and that some opposition force, the voice of the new generation, will come in and sweep everything up and take over. He thinks that will be him, and that is what impels him to found another new party.
劳合·乔治、许多喜欢古怪的人、喜欢有个性的人一起吃晚饭。保守党和工党都会非常乐意欢迎他回来。但莫斯利脑子里已经认定，通过组建这个联盟，这个国民政府，他们已经签署了自己的死刑判决，他们将无法处理经济危机，他们将被淹没，而某种反对力量，新一代的声音，将会进来并横扫一切并接管。他认为那将是他，而这正是促使他创立另一个新党的原因。
That's the new party we'll be talking about Tom after the break Okay, we will be back very soon I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull
那就是我们休息后要谈论的新党，汤姆。好的，我们很快就会回来。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们一起主持《娱乐余温》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节，我们拉开
back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Tom Moseley is a cad and a wrongan. Thatic, as I'm sure I don't need to tell you, is Stanley Baldwin's impression of Tom Sir Oswald Mosley. Baldwin, who we have described perhaps as the embodiment of parliamentary democracy in this period. And this coalition government that's been stitched together from the rump of the Labour Party, Liberal MPs, and the mass of the Conservative Party. I guess on one level, it could be cast as the will of the British
娱乐的帷幕，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。汤姆·莫斯利是个无赖和坏蛋。那，我相信我不需要告诉你，是斯坦利·鲍德温对汤姆·奥斯瓦尔德·莫斯利爵士的印象。鲍德温，我们可能已经描述过他是这一时期议会民主制的化身。而这个由工党残余、自由党议员和保守党大众拼凑而成的联合政府。我想在某种层面上，它可以被视为英国
people, this enormous, overwhelming democratic mandate that it's had. But I guess if you're on the fringes, if you despise all the various leaders of these parties who've come together, you would say that it's representative of the bankruptcy of parliamentary democracy. Do you think that's how Moseley feels? Oh, absolutely it is. And actually, I like the fact that you introduced it with Baldwin because you could take Moseley and Baldwin as polar opposites here. Moseley is charismatic, dashing, flamboyant, handsome, a man who loves the limelight. And he looks at Baldwin and he says, a little man, a nothing, an empty suit, Mr. Boring. Of course, Baldwin, uxorious, God-fearing, prays on his knees every night, sees himself as the sort of embodiment of national small-c
人民的意志，这种巨大、压倒性的民主授权。但我想如果你在边缘，如果你鄙视所有这些走到一起的政党的各种领袖，你会说它代表了议会民主制的破产。你认为莫斯利是这样感觉的吗？哦，绝对是。而且我喜欢你用鲍德温来介绍它的事实，因为你可以把莫斯利和鲍德温看作这里的两极。莫斯利富有魅力、潇洒、华丽、英俊，一个热爱聚光灯的人。他看着鲍德温说，一个小人物，一个虚无，一个空壳，鲍林先生。当然，鲍德温，宠妻、敬畏上帝、每天晚上跪着祈祷，把自己视为国家小 c
conservatism. He looks at Mosley and he says, for all his gifts, he is a terrible bounder. You know, he's a philanderer. He cheats on his wife. He cheats on his friends. Mosley can't be trusted. So they are kind of polar opposites in that way. And of course, there are more Baldwin's in Britain than there are Mosley's, it's fair to say. So Mosley goes off at the beginning of 1932.
保守主义的化身。他看着莫斯利说，尽管他有天赋，但他是一个可怕的无赖。你知道，他是个花花公子。他欺骗他的妻子。他欺骗他的朋友。莫斯利不可信。所以他们在那种方式上是两极。当然，英国的鲍德温比莫斯利多，这是公平的。所以莫斯利在 1932 年初离开了。
He goes to Italy, very bad move, because he absolutely falls in love with what he sees in Italy. The fascist dignitaries, they show him around, they say, look at all these public works, all the stuff that you wanted to do in Britain and were denied. Keynesianism, exactly. He meets Mussolini. He considers Mussolini charming. Mussolini actually says to him, I'm not sure that Britain will really go for that kind of fascism. It's not as militaristic as... So Mussolini is not a complete fool, but Moseley is completely in love with Mussolini. Mussolini is everything he wants to be, the voice of youth, the personification of vigor and dynamism and stuff.
他去了意大利，非常糟糕的举动，因为他完全爱上了他在意大利看到的东西。法西斯政要，他们带他参观，他们说，看看所有这些公共工程，所有你想在英国做却被拒绝的事情。凯恩斯主义，完全正确。他见到了墨索里尼。他认为墨索里尼很有魅力。墨索里尼实际上对他说，我不确定英国是否真的会接受那种法西斯主义。它不像……那么军国主义。所以墨索里尼不是一个完全的傻瓜，但莫斯利完全爱上了墨索里尼。墨索里尼是他想成为的一切，年轻的声音，活力和动力的化身等等。
And he comes back to Britain suffused with excitement. He's also got a new relationship, hasn't he, Tom? That I know you're very excited about. He has. So he has met with Diana Mitford, who is the most beautiful, the most glamorous, the most sophisticated star of the social scene. She is the brightest of the bright young things.
他带着兴奋回到了英国。他也有了一段新的关系，不是吗，汤姆？我知道你对此非常兴奋。他有了。所以他遇到了戴安娜·米特福德，她是社交界最美丽、最迷人、最精致的明星。她是那些明亮的年轻事物中最明亮的一个。
But let's not dwell on her and what happens with that, because we'll save that for our fourth episode, which will focus on the Mitfords. When people say she was the most beautiful girl in England, I always think, well, you've seen them all. I mean, how is that?
但我们不要纠结于她以及后来发生的事情，因为我们将把它留到我们的第四集，那将专注于米特福德家族。当人们说她是英国最美丽的女孩时，我总是想，好吧，你见过她们所有人了。我的意思是，那怎么可能？
Anyway, I don't want to be too sceptical about the Mitfords too soon, Tom, because I want to save that for episode four. So, October 1932, Moseley launches his new party, the British Union of Fascists. You know, extraordinary rhetoric.
总之，汤姆，我不想太早对米特福德一家表现得过于怀疑，因为我想把这些留到第四集再说。那么，1932年10月，莫斯利成立了他的新政党——英国法西斯联盟。你知道，他的言辞非常惊人。
Better the great adventure, better defeat, disaster, better by far the end of that trivial thing called a political career than posturing and strutting on the stage of little England amid the scenery of decadence. So this is his appeal. Interestingly, when he launches it in 1932, there is no mention of the Jews at all. So he hasn't identified the Jews as his enemy, despite the example of Hitler. But of course, he's not that bothered about Hitler. Hitler hasn't come to power yet, has he? Hitler hasn't come, exactly. Hitler has not yet come to power. Much bigger for Mosley is his pal, Mussolini, who he thinks is the big man. He's not as interested in Hitler.
“与其在小英格兰的颓废背景下装腔作势、招摇过市，不如去追求伟大的冒险，哪怕是失败、灾难，哪怕是那个所谓的政治生涯的终结，也远胜于此。”这就是他的号召力。有趣的是，当他在1932年发起这个运动时，根本没有提到犹太人。所以，尽管有希特勒的先例，他当时还没有把犹太人视为敌人。当然，他当时对希特勒并不怎么在意。希特勒还没上台，对吧？希特勒还没来，确实。希特勒当时还没有掌权。对莫斯利来说，他的伙伴墨索里尼要重要得多，他认为墨索里尼才是大人物。他对希特勒没那么感兴趣。
Well, I was just wondering, I mean, Mussolini is, of course, a militarist. He does love posing in a uniform. And if Mussolini can see that the idea of posing in a uniform might raise problems for the British, why doesn't Mosley? Because he goes for his black shirts and everything. Yeah, mostly goes for his black shirts and everything. Yeah, Mosley goes for the black shirts. I think he thinks that the spirit of the trenches, he thinks that will have tremendous appeal to younger voters. He's obviously been profoundly affected by his time in the First World War. And I think he thinks, actually, you know what?
嗯，我只是在想，我的意思是，墨索里尼当然是个军国主义者。他确实喜欢穿着制服摆姿势。如果墨索里尼能看出穿制服摆姿势可能会给英国人带来问题，为什么莫斯利看不出来呢？因为他选择了黑衫军那一套。是的，莫斯利选择了黑衫军那一套。我想他认为战壕精神会对年轻选民产生巨大的吸引力。他显然深受一战经历的影响。我想他当时心想，你知道吗？
A uniform gives us a sense of identity, a sense of glamour, all of this sort of stuff. So obviously the black shirts come from Italy. It's the Italians who had worn black shirts first. And I think he, I mean, the very fact that he calls his party the British Union of Fascists, he's perfectly happy to admit his debt to Italy. And the very first symbol they adopt is the fascis.
制服能给我们一种身份认同感、一种魅力，诸如此类的东西。所以很明显，黑衫军源自意大利。是意大利人先穿上黑衫的。而且我认为，他把自己的政党命名为“英国法西斯联盟”，这本身就说明他非常乐意承认自己借鉴了意大利。他们采用的第一个标志就是束棒（fasces）。
Which is then replaced with a lightning bolt, isn't it? On a Union Jack. And even at this stage, actually, those sort of weird eccentric people that we were talking about in the first episode who had been fascists in the 1920s, a lot of them are very suspicious of Mosley. And they say, nah, he's not really a fascist. He's not anti-Jewish enough.
后来被换成了闪电标志，不是吗？印在英国国旗上。即使在那个阶段，我们第一集里提到的那些在20世纪20年代当过法西斯分子的古怪家伙，很多人对莫斯利都非常怀疑。他们说，不，他不是真正的法西斯分子。他反犹不够彻底。
He's been an MP. He's part of the old corrupt gang of politicians. He's not extreme enough, actually, for them. I mean, Mosley's party, when he first launched this in 1932, it is fascinating because it makes a big effort to appeal to women, makes a big effort to appeal to the working classes. And it's not, you said about the militarism, he's not proposing to invade anybody or go to war with anyone. Quite the reverse. He says the lesson of the First World War is never again.
他当过议员。他是旧腐败政客集团的一员。实际上，对他来说，他不够极端。我的意思是，莫斯利在1932年刚成立这个党时，情况很迷人，因为它非常努力地争取女性和工人阶级。而且，你刚才提到了军国主义，他并没有打算入侵任何人或与任何人开战。恰恰相反。他说一战的教训是“永不再战”。
So actually, that slightly messes with one's expectation of fascism. Right. But that just, again, I mean, I understand that, that there is absolutely, weirdly, a pacifist strain to it. Certainly, I mean, he will present, certainly in the build-up to the Second World War and then during the Second World War itself, he will present himself as a leader of the Peace Party. Yeah.
所以这确实稍微打破了人们对法西斯的预期。没错。但那只是，再次强调，我明白，奇怪的是，这其中确实有一种和平主义倾向。当然，我的意思是，在二战前夕以及二战期间，他确实把自己塑造成了“和平党”的领袖。是的。
But that just makes it all the odder that he doesn't, I mean, he's a very smart guy. If Mussolini can see that going for the uniforms might be a problem, why doesn't he? I think a lot of people said of Mosley that he, I mean, that thing about him being like a child, he lacks any self-awareness and he is drunk with his own excitement. Does that make sense? Yeah, it does. Because obviously there is a sense of excitement about it. He loves the show.
但这让他显得更奇怪了，我的意思是，他是个非常聪明的人。如果墨索里尼能看出穿制服可能会是个问题，为什么他看不出来？我想很多人评价莫斯利时说，他像个孩子，缺乏自我意识，沉醉于自己的兴奋之中。这说得通吗？是的，说得通。因为显然这其中有一种兴奋感。他热爱表演。
So is that what it is, the theatricality of it? Oh, the theatricality is really important to him. He wants to be the star. He wants to put on these great theatrical spectacles. He's buoyed up by the excitement of the crowds. And action.
所以这就是原因吗，那种戏剧性？哦，戏剧性对他来说非常重要。他想成为明星。他想上演这些伟大的戏剧性场面。他被人群的兴奋所鼓舞。还有行动。
He believes in action. I mean, remember we did the podcast, Tom, with Lucy Hughes-Hallett about the Italian poet and proto-fascist Gabriele D'Annunzio. And the fascination
他信仰行动。我的意思是，记得我们和露西·休斯-哈利特一起录的那期播客吗，汤姆，关于意大利诗人兼原始法西斯主义者加布里埃尔·邓南遮。以及那种迷恋
that people had of that generation. I mean, D'Annunzio is an earlier generation. All the people that he's. And the fascination that people had of that generation, I mean, Donunzio is an earlier generation, but all the people that he's influenced, the fascination with action, fighting, violence, blood, all that stuff. I think Mosley has all that. He sees himself as a romantic hero of a great adventure story. And the uniforms, the trappings of militarism, it has a fascist defense force, 300 men. Most of them were recruited from among the unemployed. They're
人们对那一代人的迷恋。我的意思是，邓南遮是更早的一代。所有那些他……人们对那一代人的迷恋，我的意思是，邓南遮是更早的一代，但所有受他影响的人，对行动、战斗、暴力、鲜血的迷恋，所有这些东西。我认为莫斯利都有。他把自己看作是一个伟大冒险故事中的浪漫英雄。还有制服，军国主义的行头，他有一支法西斯防卫队，300人。他们大多是从失业者中招募的。他们
put up in a kind of barracks. They wear britches, they wear leather boots and all these kinds of things. Now all that, which we now see, of course, you were saying before about not projecting our own, what we know. We see all that as incredibly sinister, understandably. And some people at the time saw it as sinister. But lots of people didn't think it was sinister. They thought this is an attempt to preserve the camaraderie, the loyalty, all those things that we knew in the war. There is a massive but, which is that Moseley is upfront about saying that parliamentary democracy has run its shot, that it should be abolished, that it's long in tooth and claw. Yeah, he does say that. He wants parliament.
被安置在一种兵营里。他们穿马裤，穿皮靴，诸如此类的东西。现在这一切，我们现在看来，当然，你之前说过不要投射我们已知的东西。我们觉得这一切极其阴险，这是可以理解的。当时有些人也觉得这很阴险。但很多人并不觉得阴险。他们认为这是为了保持战友谊、忠诚，保持我们在战争中了解到的那些东西。这里有一个巨大的“但是”，那就是莫斯利直言不讳地说议会民主制已经走到尽头了，应该被废除，它已经老掉牙了。是的，他确实这么说。他想要议会。
Parliament would still exist, but people wouldn't be elected by constituencies. They would represent groups. There'd be housewives, representatives, and there'd be representatives of small shopkeepers. Coal miners. Coal miners, exactly. And it'd be a kind of corporate state. He has a very complicated blueprint, probably the most elaborate of any fascist blueprint, for a kind
议会仍然存在，但人们不再由选区选出。他们将代表不同的群体。会有家庭主妇代表，会有小店主代表。煤矿工人。煤矿工人，没错。这将是一种法团国家。他有一个非常复杂的蓝图，可能是所有法西斯蓝图中设计最精细的，关于一种
of corporate state. They'd still have the king. The king would have more power. The king would be choosing from among the various experts and you know all that sort of thing i mean the idea that george v will go for this is obviously completely bonkers because george v is so conservative but you know as we'll maybe discuss maybe one of his sons will yeah you're right so who does go for this then he makes a big effort among ex-servicemen the thing is when they get all these ex-servicemen and the descriptions of them that we have from other fascists is that basically these ex-servicemen. The thing is, when they get all these ex-servicemen,
法团国家。他们仍然会有国王。国王会有更大的权力。国王将从各种专家中进行选择，你知道诸如此类的事情。我的意思是，乔治五世会支持这个的想法显然是完全疯狂的，因为乔治五世非常保守。但你知道，正如我们以后可能会讨论的，也许他的一个儿子会。是的，你说得对。那么谁会支持这个呢？他在退伍军人中做了很大努力。问题是，当他们招募到所有这些退伍军人时，我们从其他法西斯分子那里得到的描述是，基本上这些退伍军人……问题是，当他们招募到所有这些退伍军人时，
the descriptions of them that we have from other fascists is that basically these ex-servicemen, they're people called Sid or something, they just sit around in the headquarters drinking tea and feeling miserable and talking about the Battle of Loos or something. So there's a slight sense of, I mean, basically, if you're a successful person with lots going on, you're probably not going to join this kind of
我们从其他法西斯分子那里得到的描述是，基本上这些退伍军人，他们是叫西德之类的人，他们只是坐在总部喝茶，感到痛苦，谈论卢斯战役之类的事情。所以有一种轻微的感觉，我的意思是，基本上，如果你是一个事业有成、生活充实的人，你可能不会加入这种
slightly eccentric party. So they're people who are looking for something, looking for a purpose, looking for meaning. There are lots of what people at the time would have called faddists. So people who may be drinking exotic fruit juices and spending too much time reading strange books. Well, but these are the kind of people who belong to the liberals, aren't they? So what are they doing joining the fascists? Well, maybe there's an
稍微有点古怪的政党。所以他们是那些在寻找什么东西、寻找目标、寻找意义的人。有很多当时人们所说的“狂热分子”。也就是那些可能喝着异国果汁、花太多时间读奇怪书籍的人。嗯，但这些人是属于自由派的，不是吗？那他们为什么要加入法西斯？嗯，也许有一个
interesting crossover the fruit juice crossover they would try to recruit at the rotary club at the british legion i mean they do get some people they get young people they are some used to see the by 1934 so two years into its existence, the BUF had set up branches in at least 11 public schools. So Winchester, Mosley's old school, Rishisunak School had a BUF branch, Haleybury, Millhill, Marlborough, Stowe. I don't know about Dulwich, Tom. I know you're fascinated by Dulwich.
有趣的交叉点，果汁交叉点。他们会试图在扶轮社、英国军团招募。我的意思是，他们确实招募到了一些人，他们招募到了年轻人。到1934年，也就是成立两年后，英国法西斯联盟在至少11所公立学校建立了分支机构。所以温彻斯特，莫斯利的母校，里希·苏纳克的学校也有一个英国法西斯联盟分支，黑利伯里、米尔希尔、马尔伯勒、斯托。我不知道达利奇怎么样，汤姆。我知道你对达利奇很着迷。
But also, he's appealing to people in industrial areas as well. In the North, he makes a big effort. Because, of course, that's partly what he's been doing as a Labour MP. So talking of the North, you know that one of the venues that he fills up is Usher Hall in Edinburgh, where we appeared. Really? So we were given the rest as politics stick in episode one about being in the Albert Hall with a load of fascists, centrist fascists. And we have our own dirty little secrets on. Yes, we do.
但同时，他也吸引了工业区的人。在北方，他做了很大努力。因为，当然，这部分是他作为工党议员时一直在做的事情。说到北方，你知道他填满的场馆之一是爱丁堡的厄舍音乐厅，我们在那里出现过。真的吗？所以我们在第一集里讲了关于在阿尔伯特音乐厅和一群法西斯分子、中间派法西斯分子在一起的“Rest is Politics”梗。我们也有自己的肮脏小秘密。是的，我们有。
Appearing at fascist venues. Yeah. So they got 2000 members in Leeds. They're very big with women and with aristocratic women in particular. So just look at the list. Viscountess Down, Lady Clare Annersley, Lady Howard of Effingham, Lady Pearson. There were even ex-suffragettes. So there's a quote here from an ex-suffragette called Mary Richardson. I was first attracted to the black shirts because
出现在法西斯场馆。是的。所以他们在利兹有2000名成员。他们在女性中，特别是贵族女性中非常受欢迎。看看名单就知道了。道恩子爵夫人、克莱尔·安纳斯利女勋爵、霍华德·埃芬汉女勋爵、皮尔逊女勋爵。甚至还有前妇女参政论者。这里有一句来自一位名叫玛丽·理查森的前妇女参政论者的引言：“我最初被黑衫军吸引是因为
I saw in them the courage, the action, the loyalty, the gift of service, and the ability to serve, which I had known in the suffragette movement. And Dominic, are any press barons signing up to the black shirts? So from the beginning, the BUF does try quite hard to win over people in the establishment. So they have a thing called the January Club, which is a kind of front organization. And that will get in lots of writers, lots of people who end up becoming Conservative MPs. So the two Conservative ministers in the post-war years, a guy called Alan Lennox Boyd and Duncan Sands, who was in charge of defence. So just a question. Yeah.
我在他们身上看到了勇气、行动、忠诚、服务的天赋，以及我曾在妇女参政运动中了解到的服务能力。”多米尼克，有报业大亨加入黑衫军吗？从一开始，英国法西斯联盟确实非常努力地争取体制内的人。所以他们有一个叫“一月俱乐部”的东西，是一个前台组织。这会吸引很多作家，很多最终成为保守党议员的人。比如战后两任保守党大臣，一个叫艾伦·伦诺克斯-博伊德，还有一个是负责国防的邓肯·桑兹。所以问个问题。是的。
From the point of view of the parliamentary parties, are Labour and Conservatives equally hostile to it? Does it appeal more to Conservatives? Do people in the Labour Party feel sympathy for the economic programme? Because basically, it's kind of patriotism of the right and the social policies of the left, isn't it? At this stage, I think if you were being relatively generous to the British Union of Fascists, you would say at this stage, going just by its manifesto, yes, as you say, it is protectionist, it is nationalistic, it is Keynesian economics, and it's kind of corporatist, but they're not in their official publications. They're not picking on minorities. They are talking about the old gang of politicians and all that kind of thing,
从议会政党的角度来看，工党和保守党对它的敌意是一样的吗？它对保守党更有吸引力吗？工党的人对它的经济纲领有同情心吗？因为基本上，它是右翼的爱国主义和社会政策的左翼，不是吗？在这个阶段，我想如果你对英国法西斯联盟相对宽容的话，你会说在这个阶段，仅从其宣言来看，是的，正如你所说，它是保护主义的，它是民族主义的，它是凯恩斯主义经济学，而且它是一种法团主义，但他们在官方出版物中并没有。他们没有针对少数群体。他们谈论的是旧政客集团和诸如此类的事情，
but they're not, especially in the official stuff, anti-Semitic. That said, even at the early stage, there are lots of anti-Semites in. Piling in. Yeah, piling in. But you said about Conservatives and Labour, among the personnel, far more Conservative than Labour. So you look at the list of people, there are lots of MPs who go to these January Club dinners and things. So these dinners are not branded with the BUF thing, but they're a kind of halfway house, if you like. There are lots of people with titles, Lord Middleton, El Jellico, the Marcus of Tavistock,
但他们，特别是在官方材料中，并不是反犹太主义的。话虽如此，即使在早期阶段，也有很多反犹太主义者在。涌入。是的，涌入。但你刚才提到保守党和工党，在人员方面，保守党远多于工党。所以你看看名单，有很多议员参加这些一月俱乐部的晚宴之类的。所以这些晚宴并没有打上英国法西斯联盟的标签，但它们是一个中间地带，如果你愿意的话。有很多有头衔的人，米德尔顿勋爵、杰利科伯爵、塔维斯托克侯爵，
Lord Londonderry, and so on. T.E. Lawrence, Lawrence of Arabia. Lawrence of Arabia is attracted by us. He actually writes to the secretary of the January Club, and he says, I'm really keen on your movement. I wish you well. I'm just not ready to join it myself. I think it's exactly the kind of thing that would have appealed to Lawrence.
伦敦德里勋爵等等。T.E.劳伦斯，阿拉伯的劳伦斯。阿拉伯的劳伦斯也被我们吸引了。他实际上写信给一月俱乐部的秘书，他说，我真的很热衷于你们的运动。祝你们好运。我只是还没准备好自己加入。我认为这正是那种会吸引劳伦斯的东西。
Romantic, dashing. Romantic, action, the young generation, all that stuff. Now, you mentioned press magnates. At this point, the British Union of Fascists does get admiring press coverage from, for example, the Rothermere organisation. So that is the Daily Mail or the Sunday Despatch. So the most famous instance of this, which I'm going to bring it up because I'm sure you will bring it up, Tom, and it's one that you see on social media all the time, is in
浪漫、冲劲。浪漫、行动、年轻一代，所有这些东西。现在，你提到了报业大亨。此时，英国法西斯联盟确实得到了令人钦佩的媒体报道，例如罗瑟米尔组织。也就是《每日邮报》或《星期日快报》。最著名的例子是，我要提一下，因为我肯定你会提的，汤姆，而且这是你在社交媒体上经常看到的，是在
January 1934 when Lord Rothermere writes this opinion piece called Hurrah for the Black Shirts. And this is constantly being wheeled out. And he is backing the Black Shirts partly because, well, so Martin Pugh in his book Hurrah for the Black Shirts describes him as the most influential single propagandist for fascism between the wars. Now, I don't know whether you would agree with that judgment. But just to reiterate that at this point, fascism does not mean what it has connotations it has for us. So I know that this is always used as a stick with which to beat the Daily Mail today. But there is a sense in which Lord Rothermere can back the black shirts because he's a massive reactionary, clearly, but also because he's a highly commercial newspaper magnate and he can see that there is a market here. So he's backing it not just because it's
1934年1月，罗瑟米尔勋爵写了这篇题为《为黑衫军喝彩》的评论文章。这经常被拿出来说事。他支持黑衫军部分是因为，嗯，马丁·皮尤在他的书《为黑衫军喝彩》中称他为两次世界大战之间法西斯主义最有影响力的单一宣传家。现在，我不知道你是否同意这个判断。但只是重申一下，在这一点上，法西斯主义并不意味着它对我们今天所具有的含义。所以我知道这总是被用作今天打击《每日邮报》的棍子。但在某种意义上，罗瑟米尔勋爵可以支持黑衫军，因为他显然是一个巨大的反动派，但也因为他是一个高度商业化的报业大亨，他能看出这里有一个市场。所以他支持它不仅仅是因为它
coming from his political convictions, but because he feels that he can make a profit from it. Would that be fair? I'm not sure that actually the profit motive is actually that important. I think actually, so Lord Rotherman had lost, I think, two of his sons in the First World War. He undoubtedly is on the right of British politics. And I mean, his papers have always been on the right of British politics, always very pro-empire, patriotic, worried about Bolshevism, all of that sort of stuff. I think he is absolutely, I don't think he's an outlier necessarily. I think he is a very good example of a lot of people that would include Winston Churchill, let's say, and indeed lots of conservative MPs, indeed some people in the
源于他的政治信念，而是因为他觉得他能从中获利。这公平吗？我不确定利润动机是否真的那么重要。我认为实际上，罗瑟米尔勋爵在第一次世界大战中失去了两个儿子。他无疑是在英国政治的右翼。我的意思是，他的报纸一直都在英国政治的右翼，一直非常亲帝国、爱国、担心布尔什维克主义，所有这些东西。我认为他绝对是，我不认为他一定是个异类。我认为他是很多人的一个很好的例子，这会包括温斯顿·丘吉尔，比如说，确实还有很多保守党议员，确实还有一些在
Labour Party as well, who are transfixed by the fear of communism and Bolshevism, who basically see it lurking as a spectre. I mean, not unreasonably, by the way, because an awful lot of people have died in the Soviet Union Union who think anything is better, any shield, any sword against this terrible menace. I mean, this is what Churchill is saying again and again about Mussolini, of course, in the 1920s. Anything is better than that. And of course, as you say, they don't know what we now know. Right. So that sense that reactionaries, conservatives, people who are very, very anxious about the threat of Bolshevism, that they can use the fascists as a shield. The Italian ambassador, Count Grandi,
工党里的人，他们被对共产主义和布尔什维克主义的恐惧所困扰，他们基本上把它视为一个幽灵。我的意思是，顺便说一句，这并非不合理，因为在苏联有太多人死亡，他们认为任何东西都比这好，任何盾牌，任何对抗这种可怕威胁的剑。我的意思是，这就是丘吉尔在20世纪20年代反复谈论墨索里尼时所说的。任何东西都比那个好。当然，正如你所说，他们不知道我们现在所知道的。没错。所以那种反动派、保守派、对布尔什维克主义威胁感到非常非常焦虑的人，他们可以利用法西斯分子作为盾牌。意大利大使格兰迪伯爵，
to London, he makes this point to Mosey. He notes that, and I'm quoting Martin Pugh here, that in Italy, reactionaries like Rothermere had intended to harness fascism to defeat socialism and democracy, thereby establishing themselves in power, but realised too late that they had opened the way to a real revolution in government rather than to a consolidation of the right wing. Is the Italian ambassador's take on what is happening with Rothermere's support for the fascists? I think the question that people always ask, or the emphasis that people place, is probably wrong. So people say, sort of, gosh, look at this, Isn't this shocking? Ha, ha, ha, kind of thing. Actually, the interesting thing that happens in Britain is that the people who you might expect
在伦敦，他向莫斯利指出了这一点。他指出，我引用马丁·皮尤的话，在意大利，像罗瑟米尔这样的反动派曾打算利用法西斯主义来击败社会主义和民主，从而使自己掌权，但意识到得太晚了，他们打开了通往政府真正革命的道路，而不是通往右翼的巩固。这是意大利大使对罗瑟米尔支持法西斯分子所发生的事情的看法吗？我认为人们总是问的问题，或者人们强调的重点，可能是错的。所以人们说，天哪，看看这个，这不令人震惊吗？哈哈，诸如此类。实际上，在英国发生的有趣的事情是，你可能期望
to be sympathetic to that movement withdraw their support quite quickly. Including Lord Rothermere. Yeah, exactly. Lord Rothermere withdrawing his support. So that doesn't happen in Germany or in Italy. And there's one particular moment that explains why that happens, which is one of the great sort of landmark dates in the history of the British fascist movement, which is on the 7th of June, 1934, the meeting and the violence at Olympia. So Olympia is in, where is it, it's in Kensington, isn't it? Yes. Huge kind of arena, kind of exhibition space, I guess. They're always kind of ideal home exhibitions and things like that taking place in
同情那个运动的人很快就撤回了他们的支持。包括罗瑟米尔勋爵。是的，正是如此。罗瑟米尔勋爵撤回了他的支持。所以这在德国或意大利并没有发生。有一个特定的时刻解释了为什么会发生这种情况，这就是英国法西斯运动史上伟大的里程碑日期之一，即1934年6月7日，奥林匹亚的集会和暴力事件。所以奥林匹亚是在，它在哪里，它在肯辛顿，对吧？是的。巨大的竞技场，某种展览空间，我想。他们总是举办理想家居展之类的活动，在
Olympia. And that evening on the 7th of June, 2,000 black shirts in total, in two kind of groups, marched through the streets. The biggest group sets off from the King's Road in Chelsea, marches through the streets, a great public spectacle to Olympia.
奥林匹亚。那天晚上6月7日，总共2000名黑衫军，分两组，走过街道。最大的那组从切尔西的国王路出发，走过街道，一场盛大的公共奇观，前往奥林匹亚。
There's a huge crowd outside of counter-demonstrators. By the way, the existence of the counter-demonstrators does slightly make you think, okay, this isn't just, okay, people don't know what we now know, but there are lots of people at the time who think this is not on. There is something pernicious and poisonous about fascism. A lot of those counter-demonstrators, of course, would be communists or trade unionists and things. But there is a sense that fascism is unusual, that there is some toxicity to it. So on trade unions, does Moseley want to abolish trade unions like Mussolini's done? He would make them guilds.
外面有大量反示威者。顺便说一句，反示威者的存在确实让你稍微觉得，好吧，这不仅仅是，好吧，人们不知道我们现在所知道的，但当时有很多认为这不行的。法西斯主义有一些有害和有毒的东西。当然，那些反示威者中有很多是共产主义者或工会成员之类的。但有一种感觉，法西斯主义是不寻常的，它有一种毒性。那么关于工会，莫斯利想废除工会吗，像墨索里尼那样？他会把它们变成行会。
Oh, medieval guilds. Yes, they love their medieval guilds, don't they? Yeah. So the fascists, anyway, there's a bit of argy-bargy outside. They get inside the great Olympia space. There are thousands of people there, 12,000 people in the audience, including, and this is a fascinating thing, 150 MPs. So I'm guessing most of them. All conservative. No, not all conservative. Most of them conservative, I think.
哦，中世纪行会。是的，他们喜欢他们的中世纪行会，不是吗？是的。所以法西斯分子，总之，外面有一点争吵。他们进入了巨大的奥林匹亚空间。那里有成千上万的人，观众中有12000人，包括，这是一个迷人的事情，150名议员。所以我猜他们大多数。全是保守党。不，不全是保守党。我想大多数是保守党。
The vast majority conservative. And there are dozens and dozens and dozens of society people, aristocrats, Lady this, Sir Horace that, the Earl of whatever, the Marquess of this. They're all there because they are Mosley's friends, they're his class, they're his people. And they actually probably sympathize with a lot of this. Let's fight off, let's have a fresh start. Let's get rid of all this democratic flapper rubbish. Let's get rid of communism, all that. They're all flags. I mean, it's an amazing spectacle. It's a spectacle on a scale that has never been seen in Britain,
绝大多数是保守党。还有几十几十几十个社会名流，贵族，某某女勋爵，某某霍勒斯爵士，某某伯爵，某某侯爵。他们都在那里，因为他们是莫斯利的朋友，他们是他的阶层，他们是他的人。而且他们实际上可能同情其中的很多东西。让我们反击吧，让我们重新开始吧。让我们摆脱所有这些民主的轻浮垃圾。让我们摆脱共产主义，所有这些。他们都是旗帜。我的意思是，这是一个惊人的奇观。这是一个在英国从未见过的规模的奇观，
in politics, with floodlights. I mean, everybody comments on the loudspeakers, massive, overpowering loudspeakers, Moses' voice echoing through the hall, the theatricality that we would associate with Goebbels, Tom. So the artists, of course, have been in power for a year now. Yeah. But the stagecraft is Hitler, isn't it? The stagecraft, exactly. Exactly.
在政治上，有泛光灯。我的意思是，每个人都评论扩音器，巨大的、压倒性的扩音器，莫斯利的声音在大厅里回荡，我们与戈培尔联系在一起的戏剧性，汤姆。所以艺术家们，当然，已经掌权一年了。是的。但舞台设计是希特勒的，不是吗？舞台设计，没错。没错。
But what happens at this meeting is right from the start, he's being heckled. Now, the communists had a history of, they had a track record of heckling in this way. In the debate in the House of Commons that follows this, Clement Attlee says, I think the communists have disrupted this deliberately. They do it to me all the time. So this is standard. He blames communists for it. But every time there's a heckle mostly stop speaking the searchlights are trained on the heckler and then a group of black
但这次集会上发生的事情是，从一开始，他就被起哄。现在，共产主义者有历史，他们有这种起哄的记录。在随后的下议院辩论中，克莱门特·艾德礼说，我认为共产主义者是故意破坏这次集会的。他们一直对我这样做。所以这是标准的。他把这归咎于共产主义者。但每次有起哄，莫斯利就停止说话，探照灯对准起哄者，然后一群黑衫
shirts will identify the heckler and beat him up there and then these are the the biff boys well these are much worse than the biff boy the biff boys were working for the new party these people are you know william joyce the future lord haw haw who we've talked about about. So they're kind of knuckle dusters and truncheons. Knuckle dusters, yeah, plastic truncheons. They will just kick you on the ground again and again. So like the Nazis in Germany. Exactly. The brown shirt.
军会识别出起哄者并当场殴打他。这些是“比夫男孩”。嗯，这些比“比夫男孩”糟糕得多，比夫男孩是为新党工作的，这些人是，你知道，威廉·乔伊斯，未来的“哈伊勋爵”，我们谈论过。所以他们是某种指节套和警棍。指节套，是的，塑料警棍。他们会一遍又一遍地把你踢倒在地。就像德国的纳粹一样。没错。棕衫军。
Now, some observers, it's really interesting, some of the observers, including some of the Conservative MPs, are horrified by this. And some Conservative MPs actually write a letter to the Times. One Conservative MP, Geoffrey Lloyd, I saw things at Olympia that made my blood boil as an Englishman and as a Tory. So there is a sense that this has crossed a line. Martin Pugh in his book, Hurrah for the Black Shirt, says he wonders how many of the people making these claims are actually Baldwin loyalists. And actually, they had always been fighting at British election meetings, going right back to the 19th century and did the 18th century.
现在，一些观察家，这真的很有趣，一些观察家，包括一些保守党议员，对此感到震惊。一些保守党议员实际上写了一封信给《泰晤士报》。一位保守党议员，杰弗里·劳埃德，我在奥林匹亚看到的事情让我作为一个英国人和一个托利党人感到热血沸腾。所以有一种感觉，这已经越界了。马丁·皮尤在他的书《为黑衫军喝彩》中说，他想知道有多少提出这些主张的人实际上是鲍德温的忠诚者。而且实际上，他们一直都在英国选举会议上打架，一直追溯到19世纪，甚至18世纪。
But what you don't do is shine spotlights on them. Exactly. I mean, usually it's happening on the margins. People don't want to talk about it because it's embarrassing. If you put a massive great spotlight so that everyone can see the bully boys beating up the protesters, then you're making a statement about your relationship to violence, aren't you? You're foregrounding it. Yeah. Could not agree with you more. I think that's absolutely right. I think, I was just thinking what a good point it was. I just thought it was a really good point. That of course it's different. If it's a liberal conservative election in the heyday of Gladstone
但你不会做的是用探照灯照他们。没错。我的意思是，通常它发生在边缘。人们不想谈论它，因为它很尴尬。如果你放一个巨大的探照灯，让每个人都能看到恶霸殴打抗议者，那么你就是在对你与暴力的关系发表声明，不是吗？你在突出它。是的。不能更同意你了。我认为这绝对正确。我想，我刚才在想这是一个多么好的观点。我只是觉得这是一个非常好的观点。当然不同。如果这是格莱斯顿鼎盛时期的自由保守党选举
and Israeli, drink has been taken in Markets, Snodsbury. There's rowdyism on the fringes of the meeting as Ned whatever is having a punch up with Horace so-and-so. They're shouting about tariffs at each other or whatever. Church disestablishment. That's one thing. And no one would say Gladstone has willed this. This is part of Gladstone's credo. But Mosley, not only did he train the spotlight on it, but his whole credo of action and dynamism- And strength. And strength and aggression. And non-parliamentary rule.
和迪斯雷利，在马基特斯诺兹伯里喝了酒。会议边缘有吵闹，内德某某正在和霍勒斯某某打架。他们互相大喊关税之类的。教会脱离国教。那是一回事。没有人会说格莱斯顿想要这个。这是格莱斯顿信条的一部分。但莫斯利，他不仅把聚光灯对准了它，而且他整个行动和活力的信条——还有力量。还有力量和侵略性。还有非议会统治。
Exactly. And I think there are different... Some people say Moseley might have lost control. Some people say he encourages a deliberate overreaction. I think it's perfectly plausible that he encourages a deliberate overreaction because Moseley's rhetoric is so aggressive. I'm sure he said, let's make an example of them. It will inspire people to join our movement,
没错。而且我认为有不同的……有些人说莫斯利可能失去了控制。有些人说他鼓励了一种故意的过度反应。我认为他鼓励一种故意的过度反应是完全合理的，因为莫斯利的言辞太激进了。我肯定他说过，让我们拿他们做个榜样。这会激励人们加入我们的运动，
all this kind of thing. But the furore, I think, is very damaging for Moseley. And this is what completely loses him the support of Lord Rothermere and of much of the press. So Lord Rothermere withdraws all the support of his newspapers from the BUF. He says, this has crossed a line. Now, some people say, well, he only cared about his advertisers. I'm not sure that's quite right. I think Rothermere wrote to Mosley and he said, I've noticed that there's more and more anti-Semitism in your movements and I cannot support that. But also, I think the timing is really important.
所有这些东西。但这种骚动，我认为对莫斯利是非常有害的。这就是完全让他失去了罗瑟米尔勋爵和大部分媒体支持的原因。所以罗瑟米尔勋爵撤回了他报纸对英国法西斯联盟的所有支持。他说，这已经越界了。现在，有些人说，嗯，他只关心他的广告商。我不确定这是否完全正确。我认为罗瑟米尔写信给莫斯利，他说，我注意到你们的运动中有越来越多的反犹太主义，我不能支持这一点。但同时，我认为时机非常重要。
Olympia happened on the 6th of June, 1934. On the 30th of June, it's the Night of the Long Knives in Germany, when Hitler massacres part of his own movement. That's the first, you know, for a lot of people who've been watching Hitler with interest and not necessarily with open hostility. They're very shocked by the violence, the bloodshed of the Knights of the Long Knives. And I think the coincidence of those two things means that a lot of establishment kind of Tory-ish people in Britain think, whoa, we can't have anything like this in Britain. This is absolutely crossing a line. And so actually, having attracted tens of thousands of members earlier, by the end of 1934, Mosley has lost the support of the press and he's lost loads of members. The membership is falling and his crowds are... He has a meeting in White City. His next big meeting is in White City and he gets only 3,000 people.
奥林匹亚发生在1934年6月6日。6月30日，是德国的“长刀之夜”，希特勒屠杀了自己运动的一部分人。那是第一次，你知道，对于很多一直带着兴趣而不是必然带着公开敌意观察希特勒的人来说。他们对长刀之夜的暴力、流血感到非常震惊。而且我认为这两件事的巧合意味着英国很多体制内的托利党人认为，哇，我们不能在英国有任何这样的事情。这绝对是越界了。所以实际上，在早些时候吸引了数万名成员之后，到1934年底，莫斯利失去了媒体的支持，也失去了大量的成员。成员人数在下降，他的观众……他在白城有一个集会。他的下一个大型集会在白城，他只得到了3000人。
They are outnumbered at least 20, maybe even 50 to one by crowds of counter-demonstrators. I would argue at that point, by crossing that line into violence at Olympia, he has actually already torpedoed any attempt to present his organization as a serious, respectable party of government. Martin Pugh quotes the numbers of the British Union of Fascists, that it was 40,000 to 50,000 in 1934, and it's 5,000 by 1935. Yeah. But even those figures in 1934 aren't that big. No, but don't forget most people, I mean, most political party membership in Britain
他们被至少20倍，甚至50倍的反示威者人群淹没了。我会争辩说，在那个时候，通过越过奥林匹亚暴力的那条线，他实际上已经破坏了任何试图将其组织呈现为一个严肃、受人尊敬的政府政党的尝试。马丁·皮尤引用了英国法西斯联盟的数字，1934年是4万到5万人，到1935年是5000人。是的。但即使是1934年的那些数字也不大。不，但别忘了大多数人，我的意思是，英国大多数政党成员资格
is greatly inflated in the interwar years anyway. So most of the people who are Labour Party members are actually members because they're members of trade unions, not because they're suffused with excitement. We're doing four episodes on British fascists, so I don't want to say they're unimportant. It's a bit late now, Tom. But I mean, just to emphasise that actually, I mean, it is still a very peripheral movement. Peripheral but eye-catching. Peripheral but eye-catching. And in our third episode, we will look at a particularly eye-catching incident, an incident that still has reverberations in British politics right the way up to the present day, which is the Battle of Cable Street in the East End. Very, very mythologised episode and definitely keeps the fascists in the public eye. So we will be back with that next week,
在两次世界大战之间无论如何都被大大夸大了。所以大多数工党成员实际上是成员，因为他们是工会的成员，而不是因为他们充满了兴奋。我们正在做四集关于英国法西斯分子的节目，所以我不想说他们不重要。现在有点晚了，汤姆。但我的意思是，只是强调实际上，我的意思是，它仍然是一个非常边缘的运动。边缘但引人注目。边缘但引人注目。在我们的第三集里，我们将看一个特别引人注目的事件，一个至今在英国政治中仍有回响的事件，那就是东区的电缆街之战。非常、非常神话化的事件，绝对让法西斯分子保持在公众视野中。所以我们下周会带着那个回来，
unless, of course, you are a member of the Restless History Club, in which case you can hear it straight away, and also our fourth episode, which will be on the Mitfords. Yeah, Tom, I thought you were selling yourself short there, because you basically are doing three episodes. I'm not going to say you're doing them under duress. You're doing them with great enthusiasm, and Gusto, making some very astute points,
除非，当然，你是“Rest is History”俱乐部的成员，那样的话你可以马上听到，还有我们的第四集，关于米特福德一家的。是的，汤姆，我以为你在那里贬低自己，因为你基本上在做三集。我不会说你是被迫做的。你是带着极大的热情和干劲做的，提出了一些非常精明的观点，
as we've already established. But as farress you're doing them with great enthusiasm and gusto and making some very astute points as we've already established but as far as you're concerned these three episodes are but a warm-up oh dear for the episode that you want to do about the mitt which you've been talking about since the beginning of the podcast and which i'm sad to say has been met by some skepticism by your co-presenter um about the mittford's but yes i'm so excited that i'm going to be proved wrong i can't wait and if you remember the rest is history club get stuck in listen to me being proved wrong right now you will be proved wrong you will definitely be proved wrong the mitfords are a fascinating subject uh and you can't possibly do a series on british fascists without mentioning well
正如我们已经确立的那样。但就你而言，这三集只是热身，哦天哪，为了你想做的关于米特福德一家的那一集，你从播客开始就一直在谈论，我很遗憾地说，你的联合主持人对此表示怀疑，关于米特福德一家。但是的，我太兴奋了，我会被证明是错的，我等不及了。如果你记得“Rest is History”俱乐部，加入进来，听听我被证明是错的，现在你就会被证明是错的，你绝对会被证明是错的。米特福德一家是一个迷人的主题，你不可能在不提到英国法西斯分子的情况下做一个系列节目，嗯
diana in unity i've heard you made that point about uh 500 times off air so we will see you all next time. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
戴安娜和尤妮蒂，我听说你在节目外说了500次那个观点，所以我们下次再见。再见。再见。是娱乐，这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、奖励剧集和提前。这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。